wer auf schalke spielt muss durch diesen
tunnel alle fußball stars der bundesliga
gehen hier durch wenn sie zu gast sind
beim fc schalke 04 in ein stadion mit
über 60.000 plätzen jedes mal
ausverkauft und das sind die fans
bergleute die 1200 meter unter der erde
steinkohle fördern schicht ende
nach sieben stunden einer von ihnen
helmut lauschus seit 30 jahren dabei
vorstellbar ist schon sehr viel man
arbeitet sehr viel weil hat auch nicht
die möglichkeiten irgendwie zwar eine
pause zu machen ich gehe zwar immer an
ein chaos und hole mir eine prüfungs
oder oder oder
die dreckig dafür muss man schon aber
reg reinigt den magen sagt man so schön
also wenn man von klein auf das macht
und auch nicht immer in dieser region
wohnt
und es gibt duschen zum glück haben sie
duschen erfunden und dann als zu hause
wieder sauber es ist immer schön wenn
man den kopf abschalten kann sein kann
wochenende wie blauen rufen ja doch
schon die blauen sind die frauen trifft
schalke 04 will 2000 menschen arbeiten
hier noch ende des jahres wird auch
diese zeche geschlossen
helmut ausschuss beim betriebsrat
er will wissen wie es danach weitergeht
mit ihm er ist jetzt 46 kein alter um
schon in rente zu gehen
aber nächstes jahr wird es nur noch eine
zeche im ruhrgebiet geben und er hat
glück
da kann er unterkommen bis auch die 2018
geschlossen
man könnte den eindruck gewinnen dass je
mehr arbeitsplätze wegfallen und je mehr
perspektiven natürlich auch für junge
menschen dann wegfallen der verein dann
mehr zu darauf kriegt weil der verein
gibt vielen menschen auch eine gewisse
orientierung und stärkt auch ein
gewisses zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl und
ich denke das ist gerade in einer
solchen region die wirtschaftlich sehr
gebeutelt ist auch noch mal ein aspekt
der der sehr wichtig ist im ruhrgebiet
geht gerade eine ära zu ende
aber das einzige was fuer den berg man
jetzt wichtig ist das nächste spiel
seines vereins
selbstverständlich spiel nach im
schalker stadion längst multi millionäre
aber gegründet wurde der verein als
kumpel und malocher club an diese
tradition erinnert der spielertunnel wer
einen grubenschacht nachempfunden ist
das bergarbeiter image so der marketing
vorstand ist teil des geschäftsmodells
inzwischen sind wir 105 und 30.000
mitglieder die mitgliederzahl wächst
stetig und das ohne werbliche mitglieder
kampagnen oder sonstiges ist es eine
faszination und eine bindung unserer
mitglieder auf die wir sehr stolz sind
und nur 50 prozent aller mitglieder
kommen tatsächlich aus gelsenkirchen aus
der region
das zeigt auch welche nationale
strahlkraft dieser verein hat noch zwei
stunden bis zum spiel bergleute unter
sich alle haben eine jahreskarte fürs
stadion sind 600 euro 650 euro momentan
im jahr das trikot 7000 auf jeden fall
aber diesmal muss ein sieg her
viele schalke fans haben bald nichts
anderes mehr als ihren vater